talk about some algebra maximization
with the knapsack
thank you very much opinion thank you
for inviting me so so this is based on
during work with Queen one who is that
Northeastern University and he's also
visiting for the entire semester here
assignments so as the title suggests
we're interested in the submerged
maximization problem with a knapsack
constraint so we have n items each of
them has a cost and we have a function f
on these items which we assumed to are
the Kitab to be semaj and monotone and
also non-negative and our goal is to
select a subset of these items that have
cost let's say no more than one and
subject to this we want to maximize the
value of the function so this is
probably many of you have seen this
problem before you'll immediately
recognize that it's np-hard even for a
linear objective and you might also know
that we couldn't get a 1 minus 1 over Y
approximation in polynomial time for
this problem and this is a tight in the
valuer model which is what we assume
here even if we have a cardinality
constraints all of the costs are the
same so what we'll be interested in
doing today is understanding how how can
we achieve an approximation guarantee
that is very close to 1 minus 1 over
here as fast as we possibly can so the
focus will be on running time but before
we gather let's think a little bit about
how we how do we achieve such an
approximation guarantee and and here we
can take inspiration from the classical
and AB sub problem where we have a
linear objective and one of the
strategies that we can use there to get
good algorithms is to guess some of the
more valuable items of the optimal
solution and after that simply Park
items are using a density greedy so so
we sort the items according to their
density so the city means the ratio
between the marginal gain or marginal
value and the cost and we agreed lepak
items according to density so this may
a lot of sense in the linear case what
do we but what do we mean by guessing
the most valuable items in the samara
setting so what I mean is the following
so let's let's consider at the optimal
solution and let's think about ordering
the items in the optimal solution in the
following way so first the first item in
this order will be the items that has
the largest marginal gain on top of the
empty solution so we take that item it
has the largest singleton value so we
set it aside and then after that the
next item that we we put in the ordering
is the one that has the largest marginal
gain on top of oh one this first element
we we select them so so we can greedily
order the optimal solution in this way
in such a way that at every point the
items that we are going to introduce
next has the largest marginal gain on
top of the items you know that came
before it so this is what we call the
greedy ordering above and this allows us
to talk meaningfully about valuable
items so what are the valuable items so
you can think of that as the the the
first few items are the most valuable so
as we go further along in this ordering
the marginal gain of each of these items
starts to decrease more and more so what
we can what we can show is that it
suffices to gas the first three items in
this ordering so this will be the most
valuable items that we really want to
make sure we have and after that we can
actually simply use the city greedy and
then this and the suffice is to give us
a 1 minus 1 over Y approximation but
what is the running time so the running
time is n to the first right so so so
we're guessing three items so they're n
cube triples to consider and for each of
those were using the city greedy which
run is in quadratic time right and just
I just to be clear throughout the
thought I'm going to abuse the term time
a little bit so so what I mean by time
is actually the number of
we evaluate our function so for the
algorithms that we're going to consider
that is the dominates the running time
and I'm going to simply assume that
evaluations are constant time so we can
yield an end to the fifth time if we're
happy with losing a little bit in the
approximation guarantee we can speed up
a density greedy a little bit so so we
can we can get a nearly linear time
implementation of this integrity using
something called lazy approximate
evaluations so we can bring that are
slightly down to roughly into the fourth
so so that is idea number one so idea
number two it comes from what the friend
it takes inspiration from a different
kind of algorithm for knapsack namely if
you think about the f PETA's that that
packs items social you it gets the value
when you find the minimum cost needed to
achieve that value so this is one
approach we have for the linear case and
it turns out that we can use it in the
setting as well so what is the idea so
the idea is that instead of actually
numerating over these first few items
that we consider to be valuable so
instead of actually animating over them
we're instead of going to try to admire
it over their marginal values this is
the marginal gains that they get on top
of the items that come before them so so
we'll have a small subset of valuable
items and for those we can afford to
guess their marginal gains and of course
there will be the rest of the items and
they're way too many of them and for
those we can no longer afford to guess
their marginal gain but what we can
guess is their total marginal value on
top of up one
so if we forget this then we can attract
we use an approach similar to the
classical knapsack where we are greedily
picking items in order to achieve this
marginal gains so this is not quite an
algorithm and actually terminated to an
algorithm is non-trivial and this is
where the previous work very nice paper
by actually Kumar and a young bondrock
comes in
so using this classical approach
together with the multi relaxation
framework they were able to to get a
faster running time for this modular
knapsack problem Isis also be they want
to leverage the multilinear relaxation
framework which is in some sense
necessary in the studying in order to
achieve this kind of approximation
guarantee but you also want use of this
animation ideas that I just mentioned in
order to make this as fast as possible
so their idea the high level is that
we'll have these large items I like I
like the set up one that I had on the
previous line and will have these
smaller items like the set up too and
for the large items we can afford to to
guess their marginal gains and we can
and will use those to pack them using
continuous reading right so now we're
talking a continuous problem and for the
small items we're only guessing the
total marginal gain and we'll use
continuous density greedy to pack them
to achieve that game so so it turns out
that we can implement this carefully and
get a fractional solution which we then
could round without any laws and get an
integral solution and what this allows
us to obtain is a nearly matching
approximation guaranteed in time that is
essentially a nearly quadratic in n the
number of items so you can ignore
Epsilon
so forth
so the whole name of the game in the end
of stocks would be actually improving
the dependency on and the dependency on
epsilon is it's quite high so this is a
this is somewhat impractical algorithm
because of the dependency on epsilon
that is really interesting for reasons
that are you perhaps would become a
little bit more clear later on in the
talk so so if you think of epsilon is
very small but fixed constant this is
nearly quadratic just to make sense of
this thing
am i asleep is off one like one over
epsilon to the eighth items and I'm
guessing that's exactly right
so up one is Pauline Polly one over
epsilon island and we're enumerated name
Porto spell yes and this is where this
dependency comes from which is the one
over epsilon to the eighth that's a real
that's a actually whenever have
something not a big oh whatever
you're right it's a so I should probably
have put y'all that in the exponent so
let's just say that I'm completely
normal dependencies yes and you're
absolutely right so so there we for
cardinality constrained agree d the
standard discrete really using something
ideas to get it in linear time nearly
linear time with a very good dependence
so n over epsilon times log of n over
epsilon so it's it's it's very nice and
clean there so when we go to now to the
knapsack setting things seem to be
getting much more complicated if we're
shooting for one month and so on a great
minus epsilon so that's a great question
so since Ted of at a very high level
so again shopping under the rug all of
these dependencies on epsilon that the
takeaway message is that we can solve
the multi knee relaxation in time there
is nearly quadratic in man and after
that we can run the solution very easily
in nearly linear time so this is not a
problem so really the the bottleneck for
the running time is
is the continuous time poker we solve
the continuous problem but if we step
back for a moment who might ask okay but
where is this quadratic running time
coming from and it turns out actually
that this algorithm is actually very
efficient in some sense why what the
reason is that is solving this
continuous optimization problem and it
does so by evaluating the objective only
near nearly linear number of times which
is a very nice properties is essentially
as efficient as we could hope for so the
only caveat is that every time we
evaluate this multi linear extension
this can be quite costly in terms of the
number of times we're evaluating the
original function and we are we most of
the time we spend order and evaluations
so that's that's why the running time is
the overall quadratic and for those of
you who have thought about these
problems before you will immediately
recognize that this is just a very
simple instantiation of a broader
phenomenon so this is essentially what
happens in the setting where where we're
using the multi linear relaxation and
rounding paradigm so this is the rest
this is a wonderful framework because
it's it's a incredibly general and it
allows us to get nearly optimal
approximation guarantees for a large
family of constraints but it comes with
this technical challenge that when we
relax the problem and we go to the
continuous setting what we want to do is
to optimize the multi linear expansion
and as we add we saw Ashwin and Yong
pushed this approach to the limit for
the knapsack problem in the sense that
they achieved a nearly linear number of
evaluations and this part of that the
running time still ended up being
quadratic okay so there's a there seems
to be a fundamental bottleneck here
when we employ this approach that it's
very difficult for us to achieve a
number of evaluations to the actual
function that is subhodh Roddick so see
if you want to think about this
challenge from the conceptual point of
view so that is exactly the same
challenge conceptually arises from the
from from the generic use of TT in
extension so even if we will make the
confusing optimization part as efficient
as possible if if we're using the multi
linear extension in the generic way it's
very difficult to avoid quadratic time
so so how how do we reason about this
challenge so this was our initial
motivation for looking into the knapsack
problem so we wanted to focus on the
knapsack problem because it's the
simpler setting that we know of where
this where this problem arises so in the
cardinality case we don't face this
challenge because we don't solve the
continuous relaxation but in the
knapsack case we do so so going back to
the knapsack problem so what what what
our country our specific contributions
towards this goal of understanding
whether we can do better
so what I'll show you today is an
algorithm for the knapsack constraint
that that whose a number of evaluation
with respect with your original function
f is really linear as opposed to
quadratic overall and the reason we're
able to obtain such as such a running
time is because we we do not use the
multi knee extension in a generic way so
we're actually very careful about how we
use it
so in particular we make sure that the
solution the fractional solution that
were constructing has a very bounded
functionality in the sense that the
number of entries that are strictly
fractional so they're not 0 1 these
number of fractional entries is actually
a Const
that depends on epsilon okay so this is
the way we get around this difficulty so
this allows us to make sure that when we
evaluate the multi linear expansion on
one of these fractional vectors we we do
so only at a cost of a constant number
of value queries as opposed to linear
and for those of you who are interested
the overall running time is has a nice
definition and it's n log squared but it
has this very high factor that depends
on epsilon much like the previous work
which we actually based our alder very
heavily on the previous work so so
there's much to be done in terms of
improving this dependency so but we were
only focusing on the dependency or none
social in the rest of the talk I'll try
I'll try to give you essentially the
whole algorithm
modular so many towns and in to
illustrate how some of these ideas play
next and how precisely do we ensure that
the fractional solution has only very
bound a fraction ality you can just get
a half approximation very fast yes so
that's true so this is this is all in
the name of getting very close to one
minus one agree
any other questions alright so okay so
so as I mentioned um so I'll Algrim
conceptually it's very similar to the
previous one that actually Kumar and Yun
hand it's just a different execution so
so in the picture is really what we had
before which I'm going to make a little
bit more precise so see if we remember
this picture we had at the very
beginning so I was thinking about the
optimal solution as being order
according to this greedy ordering and
I'm thinking as the first few items as
being up one so these are the valuable
items and for us specifically the number
of valuable items that we be interested
in is about 1 over epsilon Q there you
see why that is so the first one over
epsilon Q Bar my set of 1 and then the
rest will be up to and and we want to do
so we want to solve the multi-year
extension relaxation for the knapsack
problem using some guessing for the
marginal gains for for the items you not
want so so I'm going to break down the
algorithm based on are these two sets so
my Algrim will have two components one
is trying to make sure that we're
actually finding these elements that are
enough 1 or getting a value that is
comparable to theirs and the other part
here will be devoted to the elements in
table 2 and we'll do this over several
iterations because in this case it turns
out for reasons that I'm not going to we
need to increase our solution a
fractional solution a little bit more
slowly right so we're doing things
greedily so we don't want to increase
too fast
so we'll do several iterations and
they'll be one over epsilon of those so
so somebody's focus on a particular
iteration so so the first part of the
algorithm is trying to get items that
are comparable in value to of one so
specifically what do we do
so for each of the items you're not one
so remember we have one of our epsilon
cube of them we can afford to get
approximately gasps the marginal gain of
that item on top of our current
fractional solution so this is what this
is so this is the marginal gain of that
item on top of the fractional solution
and we'll get that value approximately
appropriately discretize let's not worry
about that and once we have this guess
we're going to look at all of the
elements whose marginal value on top of
the current solution exists that and
among those we'll pick the one of
minimum cost this is very much in the
spirit of the F PETA's for the four
knapsack where we want to reach a
certain target value at a minimum cost
so we'll find this item and we're going
to increase this fractional value in the
fractional solution by Epsilon so we're
fractionally increasing it by about only
epsilon at a time so this is what we'll
do in an attempt to make sure that we're
covering at one so how about up to so
for up to we can no longer afford to gas
the individual marginal gain of each of
the items and up to because there's just
simply too many of them so instead we
guess the total marginal gain that up to
has on the top of the fractional
solution so this is the gain so if we
worked out all about two on top of our
fraction solution that this is how much
we'll be getting and and here I'm
cheating a little bit so what I wrote on
the slide is not exactly correct but
it's morally and what we want to do and
I'll come back to this but for now as to
what we want to do is to use it has
density greedy to pack items integral a
to try to reach some fraction of that
marginal again how much an epsilon
tracks
so we want to do everything in
increments of Epsilon so so we are
actually going to use them city greedy
to integral if they're like items to
reach a marginal gain of epsilon times
this total gain that we guessed and the
key point here is that we're picking
these items integrally so here we were
picking on instruction land here we're
picking things integrally and of course
by the city greedy I mean lazy there's
the greedy so that it runs a nearly
linear time and so on so so so normally
this is the algorithm with some minor
details that I'm shoving under the rug
for now does it make sense so we we're
fractionally packing items proportional
to opt one and then this up one phase
and then we're packing items using this
degree integrally from then on into the
we do this one over epsilon times
so so so this is all for our for the
thinking so we don't know which are the
large value items so for me the large
body items will be the first one over
epsilon cube items in the greedy
ordering about so this is just for the
purpose of explaining the algorithm so
so this algorithm doesn't know which of
those are but the guesses are designed
to be the guesses for up one which are
the first one over epsilon cube items in
the greedy ordering and and this guess
is for the total gain or whatever is
left why am i calling it the large value
are incisors because as I go further
along in this ordering the the gain on
top of what came before starts
decreasing more and more things you're
finding yes really yes exactly so this
is the greedy ordering about only we're
not computing this and this is just in
our head right just for the purpose of
designing the algorithm so so so the
actual hologram only gets some values
which we think of as being guesses for
the marginal gains of these items we
have no idea who they are
but you're just guessing with sequence
of values no we're not guessing the
other ones are wrong I say exactly so
this is this is the the this is the kind
of the the second kind of approach that
I mentioned where instead of enumerating
or over the actual items we're at
numerating over there marginal values in
the hope that we'll gain some speed up
in the running time so this is the
algorithm so what is happening so it's
constructing a fractional solution so
what can you say about it
so the first thing we can do is analyze
it and understand is fractional value so
what we could do is essentially what we
were hoping for that the value of the
fractional solution is almost 1 minus 1
over a approximation of the optimal
value so so we couldn't show this with
some work I'm not going to go into the
details here but if we can say more
about this fractional solution which
would be very helpful
so let's think about what is happening
to the fractional solution so in
particular let's think about what is
happening in the up one phase that is
the only part where actually where we're
increasing the values of items
fractionally because thence the degree
do pick everything integrally so if you
look at our fractional solution that we
get at the very end it only have items
that are strictly fractional if we
selected them in this out one phase and
in the up one phase we put fractional
mass only on one over epsilon to the
four of these items because we do 1 over
epsilon iterations and in each iteration
we consider 1 over epsilon cube items
because that's our targets up one has
size 1 over epsilon Q so so this
destruction of solution has very bounded
our fraction ality and most 1 over X 1
to the fourth and a marble from the way
we design the algorithm
actually we can map these fractional
values to up one so we designed them to
be proxies for up one so the way you
continue by that is that we have gives
one for epsilon cube items in up one and
for each of them in these iterations we
picked about a one unit of fractional
mass and we distributed among some
elements so so these elements here they
represent one unit fractional mass and
intuitively because of the marginal
gains we can church it 2:01 because we
pick this item is of course no more than
o one and and so on so support it so
each of these items has one unit of
fractional mass that is supported on
items whose cost is no more than their
corresponding cost so this is what we
gain by by guessing the marginal gains
and picking according to them how does
this help it helps us in rounding and
this brings me to to your question so so
that we can use this to run the
fractional solution while preserving the
fractional value so we do not want to
lose any of the fractional value and at
the same time we want to bound the cost
of these fractional items that get
rounded up to one and because of this
mapping that we have in our heads we can
actually make sure that the rounding
does not exceed a budget of whose cost
is no more than the cost of up one which
is exactly what we should have happen in
the ideal case because these are all
proxies for up one okay and I can very
briefly show you how this works it's
actually the intuition for those of you
who have seen this before the intuition
is very easy so when you look at this
the first thought you might have is that
well surely we can do this it's almost
like a partition of a drain right so so
so each so I have one unit of fractional
math and I need to pick one of these
guys representing on one
and so on and indeed this is almost the
case except that some of these items are
actually straddling the boundaries so
they might be fractionally assigned to
two islands so so we need to make sure
that when we round we do not
independently choose III here and also
here okay but that's the only carriage
so so if we do this a little bit more
carefully so so so specifically what we
do is that we sort the items in
decreasing costs and we do for example
just basically swap rounding I with two
elements at a time and these elements
are the ones that have the highest cost
a fraction solution and these are all
these are only the fraction they're the
items that are
fractional as in non zero one
what other properties do you have a
budget on the size no yes so severe side
I want to make sure that they don't cost
more than op one so this is what I know
yes that's a good point
so so we do not get anything so so I'll
get to that in a minute so for now sort
of intuitively you should think that
ideally if I did everything right then
what I should add up in the purely
fractional things should be a value like
up one and cost like up one and what I
did in the density greedy phase should
have value like up to and cost like up
to ideally whether we're in the ideal
case is not unclear but at least for the
up one phase I can convince you that I
could reach the ideal state i can run
those fractional items and pay cost no
more than up one and we'll deal with up
to you know mana so so so so we just do
this a little bit more carefully and
basically we just do swap rounding
according to cost and I'm just going to
go through this very quickly and every
time in so we move fractional mass and
just like we would do it for brining or
pipe is running and we can we can every
time an item gets rounded up to one we
can pair it up with someone in up one so
so they they simply disappear and and
that's for the rounding for that part
but as chapter points out that there's
also the up to phase that we need to
worry about so so this one seems very
harmless we can round be within the
budget but what we do there and the main
difficulty is really that we need to
ensure that the density greedy phase
does not exceed the remaining budget
which is one minus the cost about one
and and this can be so as I stated the
other so this algorithm doesn't quite do
that but there's a very simple
modification of this and the reason is
that really in some sense all of these
items
it can be you can think of them as
having small cost unfortunately they do
not have small marginal gain on top of
the fractional solution which is where
the problem is but we can just fix this
using more guessing okay so so I'm not
going to say any more than this so so so
basically we're going to guess a little
bit more than what I said and it's very
easy to fix
okay so just to wrap up I so in this
talk we focus on us maximizing semaj
function subject to a single naps our
constraint and our overall goal was to
understand whether we can improve the
quadratic dependency on the running time
that seems to be Herenton the multi
linear expansion framework of course
there's much more work to be done as
we've already discussed the dependency
on epsilon is rather poor it would be
very nice to improve it maybe we can do
even something in the spirit of the
pitas that we have for linear functions
where the dependency on one over epsilon
is very good and of course the knocks of
constraint is only a starting point so
we looked at it specifically because it
seemed to be one of the simplest
settings where understanding the
quadratic barrier has seemed to require
a lot of work we're very much interested
in matrix constraints as well so I think
this is a very interesting question how
do we go beyond quadratic form eight
roads and even partition matrices it's
open thank you very much
since we're over time we can ask offline
questions